the tug-of-war over scotlands
independence is coming to a head with
the yes campaign making gains and their
pro-british opponents holding on tight
this year's highland games near aberdeen
welcomed the british monarch as usual
but Elizabeth may not be the queen here
for much longer the latest poll shows
the Scottish independence movement has
now taken the lead politicians in London
are starting to take the threat of
Scottish secession seriously promising
their northern neighbors more autonomy
if they stay in the Union sounds like so
you will see in the next few days a plan
of action to give more powers to
Scotland more tax powers more spending
powers more plans and powers over the
welfare state but the yes campaign says
Scots want full independence what I
think the pool does sure is that
increasing numbers of people across
Scotland are coming to the conclusion
that independence is the best way to
protect our NHS the best way to grow our
economy to create jobs an independent
Scotland would have one major wrinkle to
iron out the independence campaign has
said Scotland can continue using the
British Pound if it breaks away London
continues to reject that idea
you